ก็สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครู Arty สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเย้
กลับมามาเรียนภาษาไทยกับขวดอี้อี้กับครู
เอ๋
ในช่องคอมเปลี่ยนสิเบิ้ลไทยฮ่าๆใช่ครับ
ค่ะครูอัดดีคะก่อนที่เราจะพูดกันเราต้อง
พูดถึงวันก่อนค่ะใช่พูดถึงวันก่อนวันนี้
วันนี้เอ้วันนี้วันอะไรคะอะไรใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวนะสวัสตี้หาก่อนวันนี้วันนี้อ้อให้
ช่วยหานึกออกแล้ว
วันนี้วันนี้วันเสาร์ครับ
หนาวๆเหงาๆแล้ววันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันเสาร์วันพอดีพี่
ตื้อๆๆอ้าวันที่ 28 ครับ 15 ใช่ครับ
58 เขตแล้ววันที่ 18 ราคาวันเสาร์เดือน
อะไรคะอ้อเดือนนี้อ่ะกว่าตี้รู้รู้เดือน
อีกเดือนทันเวลาไรครับเดือน
ธันวาคมๆเดือนธันวาคมพ.ศ
2521 เย้ปีคศ 2000  21 ใช่ครับมีผชเท่า
ไหร่คะมีผช
564 อ้าใช่ครับ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะอ่ะพรุ่งนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
พรุ่งนี้ก็วันนี้วันวันเสาร์พรุ่งนี้ก็
ต้องเป็นวันอา
ทิตครับวันอาทิตย์ออก
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
อาทิตย์วันที่
19 ครับอ่าพรุ่งนี้ใช้ครับอ่า
29 ครับวันนี้วันเสาร์พรุ่งนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ได้ครับอันนี้วันอะไรนอกเมื่อวาน
นี้เมื่อวานนี้วันนี้วันเสาร์เมื่อวานนี้
อ้าวันศุกร์ครับเมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์หน้า
ใช่ครับหน้าวันศุกร์
อ๋อ
โอเคนักเรียนรู้จักวันนี้เมื่อวานนี้อ้า
ใช่ครับชาร์จวันนี้คลิปนี้ตอนนี้เวลาตอน
นี้ใช่ไหมครับ
แต่ตอนนี้เวลา
10:00 น
10:00 นกี่นาทีครับหนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้าหก
เจ็ดแปดเก้า
สิบนาทีได้มะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
อีกพอ 10 นาที
โอเคค่ะครู Arty ตอนนี้พี่เอ๋มีเรื่องจะ
เล่าให้ฟัง 5 มีเรื่องอะไรครับเดี๋ยวครู
เอ๋เอ๋ช้าสกรีนนะหาได้ครับขวดดิเอ๋วิ่ง
งวด
สักครู่นะคะหน้า
โปรดอนุญาตด้วยโอเคนะ
มี
อะไรคู่ Arty ต้องอนุญาตครูเอ๋แชร์ท้อขอ
โอเคขวดตี้อันดิ / หัวตี้ลืมลืมว่าตี้
อนุญาตตรงไหนตรงชัยสกรีน
เพลงเดี๋ยวนะกวนตี้หาก็ก่อนจะมีคลิกก่อน
อะที่ 2
มัลติ
Share  screen โอเคอนุญาตแล้วครับ
โอเคนี้กูอาร์ตี้
จ้าครับผมมาแล้วนักเรียนเห็นแล้วเสร็จเรา
แล้วให้แล้วใช่ครับมาอ่ะกูเอ๋มีเรื่องจะ
เล่าให้ฟังเป็นเรื่องที่รัก
เบื่อปี 1919
[เพลง]
รอเดี๋ยวนะ
1999 ประมาณ 1997 มั้งอ่อ
1997 คิด
1997 หรือ
1998 เนี่ยอ๋อเหรอครับครูเอ๋ลืมปีอะไร
ฮ่าๆลืม
เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนอามานานแล้วลืมลืม
กอล์ฟครูเอ๋ใช่มั๊ยเค้าจะมีครูเอ๋
ครูเอ๋
แล้วก็เพื่อน
เพื่อนเพื่อนมีผู้ชายผู้หญิงอ่ะอ๋อมีคู๋
แล้วก็มีเพื่อน
มีนักเรียนด้วยอ่ะมีนักเรียนไปด้วย
ได้มีคนฝรั่งเศสเรียน
มีคนถ้า
ไม่ใช่ฟักไม่ใช่สัตว์คนฝรั่งเศสฝรั่งเศส
อ่ะ
มีคนญี่ปุ่นห้องมีคนญี่ปุ่นด้วยใช่ไหม
ครับว้าวเพราะมีเพื่อนหลายๆคน
ไปที่ภูเขาค่ะขอ think  or ไปที่ภูเขากัน
หลายๆคนค.คิดไปภูเขาทำ to ขาวเนี่ยจะมีมี
น้ำตกขอมีน้ำตกที่บุ๊คเห่าด้วยหูเอาต้อง
สีน้ำตาลลืม 8 น้ำตกพี่ปุ๊กข่าวแค่น้ำตก
แล้วก็มีแม่น้ำ
ครูครูเอ๋แล้วก็เพื่อนใช่มั้ยครูเอ๋เอ๋
แล้วก็เพื่อนเพื่อนๆเพื่อนๆคิดออกน้ำตก
น้ำตกอ่าก็เลยเช่ารถเธอช่วยหาอ๋ออ๋อ
เช่ารถ
รถตู้ไป
แล้วก็ทุกคนครับที่รถอ๋อ
อยู่ที่รถตู้หา
ภูเขาครับไปภูเขาแต่ถนนเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะ
ฮ่าๆ
ๆพรุ่งนี้ก็ภูเขาภูเขาเขา
ถนนนะกู Arty เดี๋ยวกูอีกว่าให้ดูหน้ารถ
ติดลบมันหนักหนาถนนแนวๆ
เป็นอะไรเสียงอาหารๆ
8 หมดหรือเปล่าครับตี๊ดตี๊ดตี๊ดแบตหมดรึ
คิดว่ามัน I  ok อา
เกาะถนนนะคะเขาจะโค้ง
โค้งแบบนี้น้าครับผมไปมาไปมา
อาจเป็นเขาก่อนเจ
[เพลง]
อันนี้ถนนนะคะถนน
ถนนโค้ง
คือครูเอ๋กับเพื่อนก็นั่งที่รถแล้วรถก็
เลี้ยวซ้ายเลี้ยวขวาขึ้นข้างบนลงข้างล่าง
คงไปมาขาวทุกคนนะเอ่อ
ใช่เหงาเวียนหัวนะฮะ
เป็นอะไรครับ
เป็นอะไรอ่อรอบขวดฉี่ปวด
ที่มีแต่เราก็หา
ไม่มีปั๊มน้ำมันเอสโซ่ซีเบลมายมี
มีแต่ต้นไม้
ต้นไม้มีต้นไม้
ต้นมาให้
โชเฟอร์ตอนนี้มีโชเฟอร์คนขับใช่ไหม
โอเปอร์
ทุกคนจอฟ้าปวดฉี่ปวดทีโชเฟอร์ใจเย็นๆใจ
เย็นๆรอเออนิดหน่อยอ่าแป๊บนึงเอารอรอรอ
นิดหน่อย
เข็มจะมีจะมีหมู่บ้านอ๋ออ๋อมีหมู่บ้าน
หมู่บ้านมีฝ้าบ้านเขาภูเขาโอเค
ก็ไป
ฮะโอเคอ๋อ
ทุกคนอดทนอดทน
ลดก็ไปไปไปจนถึงที่นี่หมู่บ้านก็
อยู่ที่นี่ล่ะ
หน้าโอเค
ว้าวถึงแล้วเย้
ทุกคนหนึ่ง
Q2 ปวดฉี่ปวดฉี่
ที่หมู่บ้านมีก๋วยเตี๋ยวน้องโอเคได้กิน
กินกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวคนก็เปิดประตูรถ
มีประตู
เกาะเปิดแล้วก็ลงนะคะ
R ขึ้นที่หมู่บ้านมีคน
จะ Mini คน
คนก็บอกดูสีอ่ะ
ก็ต้องแต่งนุ่นขอ
เขาชี้ไปไปไปทางนี้ทางไหนด้วยค่ะครูอติ
ที่ทางไหนครับบางนี้ค่ะซื้อ
อ๋อ
มีห้องน้ำ
แล้วก็ตรงนี้มีแม่น้ำ
มีแม่น้ำมันอ๋อเขาก็ชิ
โอ้ยทุกคนก็วิ่งคู๋ที่ 1 เนี่ยอุ้ย
ไปที่ห้องน้ำหรือวันนี้มีต้นไม้
ต้นไม้ค่ะนี่มีทางแล้วก็มีต้นไม้ไม่คุยก็
วิ่งไปที่ห้องน้ำคนที่ 1 หยุด a ห้องน้ำ
คนที่เหน่งอ่าโอเค
f เปิดประตูห้องน้ำปืนหน้าเป็นไงพูดจริง
ๆปวดฉี่มากและก็เปิดประตูห้องน้ำ
หูขนที่หน้าอ้าๆคนเป็นไงครับ
แขนตรงนี้ละกันใช้หนี้วะแขนคู๋
นี่มืออันนี้ขนลุกขึ้นมาขอ
ขนลุกคนแบบมึง
[เพลง]
กู S เห็นเท่าไหร่ครับอ่าตกใจเห็นหนอนะคะ
ล้อหนอนหนอนเรียนรู้จักหนอนไหมเนี่ยหนอน
สีหนอนเดี๋ยวไปวาดให้ก็ได้
นอนคุยวัดอย่างนี้แล้วกันคุยกวนออกไม่ชอบ
นอนฮ่าๆๆหนอนขอ
อวดดีเข้าใจแล้วหนอนให้มันเป็นสีดำอ่าอ๋อ
หนอนตัวสีดำไม่มีขน
ไง
อ๋อ
แล้วก็เข้าบาทข้างไหนอ๋อเข้ามาในห้องน้ำ
วัดคุกนี่
ต้องน้ำก็เป็นแบบนี้ค่ะผัว Arty
ห้องน้ำก็เป็นแบบนี้
เป็นแบบนี้
แล้วก็มีหลังคา
มีเสาอาครับกู Arty อยู่ที่เนี่ยอ๋ออยู่
ในห้องน้ำอยู่ข้างในห้องน้ำมองเห็น gay
Anime อตี้อ่ะ
แล้วต้นไม้
ต้นไม้อยู่ดีๆอาจนี้เข้าบ่ายโอ๊ย
น้อ
หนอน
หนอนนอนๆๆๆๆ
หนอนต้นไม้นี่หนอนมากๆอ๋อมีหนอนมากบนต้น
ไม้โอเค
เว็บผู้หญิงใช่มั้ยแล้วก็เด็กๆอ่ะอายุ
20 เท่าไหร่ 23  25  26  27  28
ประมาณอายุประมาณ 29
เห็นหนอน
ค้นหา
ลุค
เวียนมันขยะแขยงร้อน
คุณคู๋เห็นหนอนแล้วนี่นา
สวัดีรู้สึกนี่มั้ยนอนที่ไม่รู้เห็นกูอะ
ที่เห็นหน่อย
โอเคไม่ยี้
ถ้าภาพตรงนี้
มีนก
นก
นาดนะ
นกนกตายแล้วก็มีหนอนหนอนหนอนๆๆนก
อ่านิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยรึ
อยู่ในนก
พี่ผู้ชายคนนี้ไม่
ใช่เวลาเราเห็นอ๊ะรู้สึกยิ่งเห็นหนอนใช่
ไหม
ถ้าไม่ชอบแล้วก็รู้สึกก็เคยกับภาษาไทย
ด้วยว่าขยะแขยงอ๋อขยะแขยงขึ้นแล้วคือชอบ
อือ
อยากเดี๋ยวเราพานักเรียนไปดูนะอะไรที่
เขียนแล้ว
อ่า
อันนี้ครูเห็นหนอนแล้วคุยอ่าโอเคไปดูว่า
อะไรที่เห็นแล้ว
นี่ไหมคะขวดตี 5 มีครับเปิดที่มีเยอะเลย
เตรียมมาให้ครูเอ๋เลยวันนี้นะครับ
มีอะไรบ้างใช่ไหมครับที่เห็นแล้วนะครับ
ตัวแรกคู๋พร้อมไหมครับพร้อมไหมท้อไหม
อันนี้ก็ได้ค่ะถุงอ่ะอ่าใส่ผ้าถุง
โอเคเก๋
ปิดปิดแอร์เวย์ส
r123 ไป
ไปครับนี่ไงพี่ตัวอะไรครับอ่ะตัวอะไรครับ
อ๋อ
วิ่งคือๆโอเค
กิ้งกือนะเมื่อก่อน
เวลาทุกเอ๋อายุ 7 ปีชอบนี่อ๋อ
อากิ้งกือ
1 วันกูอีกจับกิ่งกือแล้วก็ดม
kuai นะ
ยิ่งคือกันดินดินดินดินดินดินกินเกิดครับ
เฮ้ยดมคอนโดว่ามันจะแล้วคู่เอกอ่ะอ๋อ
จริงเกิดมี
ขนลุก
ปาร์ตี้รู้สึก
ควรตี้เฉยเฉยๆไม่รู้สึกเขาไม่รู้สึกกูเอง
ไม่เลยๆเก๋ๆคนรู้เออ
ขยะแขยงถ้ามีกิ้งกือกิ้งกือกิ้งกือ
กิ้งกือเยอะขยะแขยงอยู่
หมดเลยเออมีอะไรอีกข้ามีอะไรอีกใช่ไหม
ครับอ่ะมีกิ้งกือมีอีอุตัวใหญ่มาก
เออ
ตะขาบปันข่าวใช่เขาๆตัวนี้ก็จะข่าว
เหมือนกันนะครับเองเคยเจอตะขาบไต่เอาไป
ขับตายรึ
ดีขึ้นมาบนแขนใช่มั้ย
กูตั้งแต่ตั้งแต่นี่เลยค่ะขอโทษนะคะไม่
เห็นมาหาเรียบร้อยไหมเนี่ยข้างล่างเป็น
เพราะถุงค่ะอ๋อเห็นไหมเนี่ยอ้ามันกัดขาไป
ขึ้นมาขา
ขึ้นมาตัวอาหารแล้วผู้เองนอนอยู่เหรอครับ
นอน
อะไร
อิอิ
ขอ
ขนลุกเลย
จบออกไป
[เพลง]
ขยะแขยงค่ะขยะแขยงใช่ไหมครู Arty กับคือ
ตะขาบมีขา
ใช่ครับอ้ามีขามากนี่มีขาเยอะขาขาโป้ขาขา
ขาขาขาชายอาอานาจริงตื่นแล้วคะมีขามากๆ
ไหมจริงตื่นก็มีขามากยิ่งคือมีขามากนี่มี
ขาป้าโอ๋
มากกว่าตะขาบเนาะๆมีขามมากกว่าตะขาบอ่ะใน
กิ้งกือไม่ใส่รองเท้า
ทางกิ้งกือใส่รองเท้ากิ้งกือไปไหนไม่ได้
โทษขายรองเท้าไม่เสร็จรองเท้าใส่รองเท้า
ให้ซื้อคะ
คือใส่รองเท้าไม่ไหวใส่รองเท้าไม่ไหวรอง
เท้าต้องเยอะมาก
ฮ่าๆ
จิ้งกือไม้ใส่รองเท้า
รองเท้าน่ะรองเท้า
อ่านที่คือไม่ใส่เสื้อ
อย่าชื่อไอ้เก็บและมีเอายิ่งไปก่อน Play
a
is
girl มีตะขาบแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับพี่
มีอะไร
กว่าตีมีอะไรอีก 5 ขวดที่มีมีเมื่อกี้
เมื่อกี้คู๋พูดพูดถึงนอนใช่ไหมหนอน R ตัว
ที่มีรูปหนอนมีรูปหนอนมีรูปหนอนน่ารักๆ
ตัวสีเขียวน่ารักนี่เหงาตัวนี้ครับนอนน่า
รักตัวสีเขียวอ่า
เวลานอนเดินเนาะเป็นดื่ม HD คือ
แบบนี้อ้าเงิน
เป็นดึกกระดึบกระดึบกระดึบ
นรวีร์กันของ
กูอาทิตย์สอนหรอคะอ่ะแน่นอนน่ารักไม่น่า
รัก
โอเคเองไม่ชอบหนอนอ๋อไม่ตอนที่อ๋อโอเคอ่า
มากๆ
มีกิ้งกือคือมีตะขาบมีหนอนนะครับอ่าแล้ว
มีแต่นะมีอะไรที่คู่เอ๋แจง
[เพลง]
ครับอ้าโหดูเลือดเรา
กูอ่ะพูดถึงพูดถึงตัวนี้แน่ๆตัวนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับ 5 นี้ครับอาร์มันดูดเลือด
ลืม
เลือกดูดเลือดของเราก็ไปแต่แล้วมันก็อ้วน
ก็ได้แล้วตัวมันจะใหญ่คืนยายคืนใหญ่คือนา
เป็นตัวใหญ่แล้วมันสีแดง
ไปครับมีตัวนี้พี่เลี้ยงอะไรครับเรียก
อะไรครับ
อ๋อถ้า
อาท่าบวชเดือนหูเห็น 1 ตัวภาคนะเห็น 1
ตัวเนี่ยขาวขนลุก
แล้วแบบไม่เห็นภาค 1  2  3 โอ้มีทางหลายๆ
ตัวใช่ไหม
ตายบดีดีดูดเลือดอยู่เดือนหมดตัว
ทราย
เฮ้ย
[เพลง]
โอเคยิงกลืนอ้ะเห็น 1 ตัวครูเอ๋โอเคนะคะ
เดินไกลๆ
เห็นกิ้งกือกิ้งกือ
50 ตัว 20 ตัวกูเองเย้เย้พญาแขยง
[เพลง]
กระทากอ่ะทากน่ะเห็น 1 ตัวหาเลยใช่ไหม
ไม่จับมาไม่จับถ้า
เอ๋ขนลุกขนลุกอธิยาแขยงใช่ไหมครับอ่าขยะ
แขยงมา KR แล้วมีตัวอะไรอีกอ่ะมีอะไรกู
กับกี้อะไรอีกอ่ะขวดอีกอูเอแจ็คเสียบแขยง
ไหมอ่ะที่ที่ที่บ้านที่บ้านครัวตี้มีตัว
นี้ด้วย
นี้มีตัวนี้ครับอ้าอันนี้นี้มีเสียง
ได้
จิ้งจกได้ครับเนี่ยตกครูเอ๋ชอบนะอ๋ออ๋อ
ไม่ขยับแขยงก็ไม่ขยะอ๋อแต่แต่ว่าแต่ว่า
อ่ะเพื่อนเพื่อนๆครูเอ๋น่ะเห็นจิ้งจกแล้ว
ขอ
จบ
กับกูเองไม่ชอบอันนี้ค่ะขี้จิ้งจกขอจริง
ถูกมีขี้ด้วยใช่ไหมขี้จิ้งจกสีดำมีที่สี
ดำ
เป็นน่ากลัวที่ต้องวาดตรงนี้สีดำมีสีขาว
อยู่ด้วยใช่ไหมพี่สาวต้องหัว
คู๋นี่อ่า
[เพลง]
โอเคอ่าต้องออกพรุ่งนี้ใช่ไหมครับโอเคๆ
เหมือนว่าถึง
ขี้จิ้งจกอ่ะดอกเออโอเคอ๋อๆที่บ้านบ้าน
ครูเอ๋มีจิ้งจกจิ้งจกจริงปิ้งจบไม่ฮะโอเค
แล้วพ่อครูเห็น
ขออยทรายมีตีรู้สึกขยะแขยงจิ้งจกไหมคะอ่ะ
หัวตี้ไม่รู้สึกไม่รู้สึกจิ้งจบ
แล้วที่บ้านมีจิ้งจกไหมคะมีครับมีจริงกะๆ
ขี้ไหมคะจิ้งจกขี้ครับมากๆมั้ยไม่มาค่ะ
เพราะว่ามีจิ้งจกไม่เยอะมีจิ้งจกเอ่อน่า
จะ 2 ตัว 3 ตัวไม่เยอะไม่เยอะ
ยิ่งจบช้อปปิ้งแล้วก็เข้าบ้านออกฮ้อก็บ่
คุยกับจากโอ้โห 10 ตัวเยอะมากมากเมื่อวาน
มาห้องนี้ 3 ตัวกูเองจับอ่า
เมื่อ
เทอญ
ข้างนอกโอเคอ๋อนอนไม่อด
ห้ามๆขี้มันน่ะค่ะกูเอง
โอเค
นักเรียนเห็นจริงจุกโอเคมั้ยใช่ครับขยะ
แขยงไหมไอ้นี่ไหม
ไม่อยากแขยงอ๋อ
มีอะไรขยับน่าขยะแขยงหน้ามีจริงจกแล้วมี
ตัวใหญ่กว่าใหญ่กว่าจิ้งจกอะไร
อะไรตัวนี้ครับอบปปปๆๆ 6 แต่หาเคยได้ยิน
เสียงด้วยมีเสี่ยงด้วยครับตัวนี้ครับอ่าๆ
ตัวนี้ตุ๊กแก่
อาเจ๊โกะ
นักเรียนไม่ได้กลัวมากๆไม่ใช่นะคะแต่แบบ
ขนลุง
ตัวนี้ตัวใหญ่กว่าจิ้งจกงาตัวใหญ่กว่า
จิ้งจกสีแดงนายตาสีแดง
ตัวข้อสีแดงมีลายลายสีแดง
ขยันใช่ไหมจะแพงอ๋ออ๋อทรายกบแพงแกตุ๊กแก
แพงๆครับอ่ากินได้กินได้แต่กูกติกินไว้
มายกินก็ไม่กินก็คุย
นักเรียนรู้สึก
รู้สึกขยะแขยงไหมครับ
ขยะแขยงเรื่องราคาเดี๋ยวอามีอีกตัวนึงตัว
สุดท้ายตัวสุดท้ายอ่ะตัวนี้ครัวตี้ก็ไม่
ขยะแขยง
ไม่แขกแขยงตัวนี้ครับตัวนี้อ่าชอบไหมอ่า
เฉยเฉยๆไม่ชอบโอเคโอเคตัวนี้ครับไม่ขยะ
แขยงเขา
คืนนี้ตัวนี้อาซายเดือน
ไส้เดือนเวลาฝนตกแล้วฝนตกมีไส้เดือนตำ
พื้นตามพื้นใช่
นะ
เห็นโอเคอ่ากลับไม่โอเคน้อ
เห็นอ่ะโอเคสวัสดีใช่เรือนบ๊ายบาย
จับนะจากไม่ได้พอ
ก็กลับโอเคโตจับอ่าใช้เดือนนิ่มๆรึๆ
นิ่มๆได้ครับ
ไส้เดือนดีนะคะ d5 ทรายขาวไส้เดือนดีดี
ถ้าครูเอกจะจับต้องมีถุงมือขอใส่ถุงมือ
ถุงมือใส่
แล้วก็จับโอเค
อ้าโอเควันนี้เรามีสัตว์ที่ขยะแขยงนะครับ
อ่ะขยะแขยง
เห็นแล้วขยะแขยงหลายตัวมีอะไรบ้างนะครับ
มีอะไรบ้างครับมีหนอนมีหนอนอันที่ 1 อัน
ที่หนึ่งเราพูดถึงตัวนี้นี่คือนะครับแล้ว
ก็มี
ตะขาบหน้าแล้วก็มีอี
ดอกอ่ะโอเคแล้วก็ตัวนี้ครับตัวใหญ่กว่า
ที่จบตุ๊กแก
โอเคมีตุ๊กแกแล้วก็มีตัวนี้ครับที่กูเอ๋
เอ่อกูกลัวที่สุดกูกลัวกลัวๆที่สุดตัวนี้
เขา
หนอนอ้าแล้วก็อ้าแล้วก็มีไซส์คะท่าน
ให้เดือนแล้วก็มีอีกตัวนึงตัวสุดท้ายก็
สุดท้ายนะครับอ่ะถ้าตอนนี้อ่าโอเคอ่าวัน
นี้เราเรียนเรื่อง
สัตว์น่าขยะแขยงน่าขยะแขยงมาเกย์นักเรียน
ขยะแขยงไหมอ่าเรียนชอบ
นักเรียนแขยงอะไร
แข็งตัวอะไรครับครู Arty โอเคทุกตัวอ้า
ควยตี้ก็เฉยๆเฉยๆๆๆ
กูเอ๋ขยะแขยงนะคะ
โอเคค่ะคลิปนี้นะคะเราสองคนไปก่อนหมดเวลา
อ้าให้ครับไม่เวียนคอมเม้นท์บอกครูขยะ
แขยงอะไรนะคะ
แล้วเดียวเข้าหน้ากลับมาเจอกันใหม่ในช่อง
คอมพรีเฮนเซเบิลไทยนะครับวันนี้ครัวตี้
อ่ะสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋โกเอ๋สวัสดีครับนัก
เรียนไวท์บายโอ